[Music]
we always look at nature
as a source of inspiration hermes very
lightweight structure
replicates a neural network its
complexity and efficiency
the foam is a representation of a
traditional chinese lantern
created for the gardens by the bay's mid
autumn festival
our goal was to create a slight a
structure as possible
by spreading the forces into very thin
elements throughout 3d printing
it drastically reduces the use of
materials
and the entire structure's embodied
carbon footprint
for the user the idea is that the
structure matters less
it is about the enjoyment of the
surroundings
behind the outward simplicity of the
hermes pavilion
there's a complex and robust structure
delivering the experience
we design a whole new construction
system that allows for more adaptable
and freeform designs as compared to more
traditional space frames
that are limited by standardized nodes
bars and angles using 3d printing in
stainless steel
each of its bespoke joints is
computationally generated
integrating a concealed connection
system
that simplifies dramatically the
construction sequence
so connecting a node to a bar is akin to
assembling
one big piece of ikea furniture
in a sense we have made an ultra high
performance structure
accessible to more people that allows
for rapid deployments
what's also great is we have actually
managed
to achieve zero wastage material in its
construction
airmesh has set the precedent not just
for singapore but
truly for the world on the possibilities
of 3d printing technologies
in our built environments this small
pavilion
has punched above its weight and already
gotten the world's attention
we are ready to scale the system to
design bridges
long-span shelters or multi-storey
spaces
to bring across our confidence in this
technology
and blaze a path for the future of
construction in singapore
[Music]